little man
the doubter said man cannot fly the doer
said maybe
but we'll try and finally soared in the
morning glow
while non-believers watched from below
bruce lee
i just passed a really important
milestone that i'm excited to share with
you
but first a story 11 months ago i set a
goal for myself
i wanted to create a motivational video
for entrepreneurs because i know how
hard it is to wake up
every day and follow your dream even
when the people around you may not
support you
i spent five months trying to make my
goal work
i had the goal but i didn't have the
skills or the know-how
i needed help i reached out to people i
knew
asked friends for help looked at who the
best people in the world
at doing these videos were i made it my
goal
i made it important and slowly things
started to happen
after a lot of questioning looks and
rejections i found my team
and got to work we made a great video
i was so proud of it i watched and felt
man
i'm honored that my name is on this it
felt
so good it was six
minutes and three seconds of pure
awesome
so i showed it to some people in the
video and publicity business
the response seven words
no video should be six minutes ever
so i wrote back showing that all the ted
talks which are extremely popular
are all over six minutes his response
the average length of the top 50 videos
on youtube was 2 minutes and 54 seconds
please tell me you actually understand
how the internet works
so by his logic because the average
video is 2 minutes and 54 seconds
my video can't be six minutes and be
popular
it's comical but it's also really
important
you see the younger evan might have
listened to him after all this guy is an
expert in making videos and getting
publicity
you should always listen to expert
advice right
i've never made a video like this before
what do i know
here's what i know eleven months ago
when i set my goal i was excited
about it i felt it was something that
people needed
that i needed the finished product was
something i was so proud of creating
i wasn't about to let this little man
take my goal away from me
even if he is an expert even if he knows
what he's talking about
when you find something that you're
passionate about you have to keep going
even when people tell you you're crazy
even when people tell you that this will
never work
even when you start to doubt yourself
because the world belongs to the
unreasonable men and women
who follow their hearts and build
amazing things
you will never be truly happy have a
real impact on this world or make lots
of money
if you base your decisions on the
results of other people's thinking
especially when that other person is the
little man
so trust the dots will connect somewhere
in your future
trust that even if you only see darkness
around you right now
things will work out trust that by
following your heart you will reach your
goals
and help change the world and stop
listening to the little man
oh and my six minute wait too long video
we just crossed 500 000 views on it
believe